[Music]
in this problem anerobic digestion is
used to treat primary sewage generated
at a 10 MGD wastewater treatment plant
the following data are provided the mean
cell residence time in the digestor is
10 days the anerobic digestor volume is
20,000 cubic feet the sludge specific
gravity is
1.04 and the dry solids removed in the
primary tank is 13,000 pounds per day
the goal is to find the moisture content
of the primary sludge expressed as a
percent so in this problem the first
thing we're going to want to do is go to
our reference manual and if we search
sludge this will eventually lead to
chapter 6 section
6.8.9 point3 called activated sludge
treatment and if you go a little further
down to page 457 you'll find a
subsection called sludge production it
it's here that we're going to need the
equation that the reference manual
provides so the sludge production
equation is given as follows V Subs
equal m over P
Subs S
Subs
GW where in this case v Subs is the
sludge volume produced in cubic feet m
is the sludge production rate on a dry
weight basis in pounds
Force GW is the specific weight of water
in pounds Force per cubic
foot S Subs is the specific gravity of
the sludge slurry and P Subs is the
percent of solids expressed as a
decimal so before we can use this
equation the first thing we need to do
is find V subs or this daily sludge
volume
[Music]
produced so the daily sludge volume is
going to be given in units of fet cubed
per
day to get that we want to
divide the digestor
volume by the cell residence
time this value is sometimes given as
Theta
C so our digester
volume is 20,000 cubic feet and our cell
resonance
time is 10 days so this gives the daily
sludge volume at
2,000 cubic
feet per
day we now have enough information for
the sludge production equation to fill
out all of the terms except for one
which in this case is going to be P Subs
which again is the percent of solids
expressed as a
decimal so for step
two we're going to back
calculate using the Sledge production
[Music]
equation so V Subs we said is
2,000 cubic feet per
[Music]
day and that equals
M which is the dry solids removed in the
primary
tank of
[Music]
13,000 pounds per
day this is going to be over P
Subs S Subs is it our specific gravity
of
1.04 and and finally the unit weight of
water or the specific weight of water is
going to be
62.4
pound per cubic feet now that's a term
that wasn't given but it's one that you
should know so either have it memorized
or look it up in the front of the manual
uh during this problem obviously it'll
be faster if you have it
memorized from here we can isolate P
Subs and that's going to
be
0.1 which is the
percent of
solids expressed as a
decimal so to finalize this
problem all we need to do is find the
moisture content instead of the percent
of solids so
so the moisture content equals 1 minus
the dry component equals the wet
component in this case that's going to
be 1 minus
0.1 to give us
0.9 or
90% And we can see over here that this
is the third answer so that's all it
takes to solve this problem you need to
know the sludge production equation
which we found in the reference manual
and before you begin to use it you need
to find the daily sludge volume by using
the digestor
volume and the resonance time
provided calculating for the sludge
production can use the remaining terms
up
here and finally we have to subtract the
dry from the total to get the wet it's
worth mentioning that the flow rate or
size of the wastewater treatment plant
the 10 MGD number here is not
used and that the test is going to give
you the answer for the dry component to
in case you either get confused for what
you're solving for or you're in a hurry
and you picked the first answer from the
middle of your
calculations but if you can avoid those
minor pitfalls this problem's pretty
straightforward and that's it